the fate of the universe is at stake so
this is f ed always together we can stop
him
they Jin - the Avengers mayor of
smartest heroes never heard of them
BTC that every Kinkos fun fee
cool so cool
[Music]
it's a very interesting time now and boy
you don't know what's gonna happen I
know that I'm proud of it I know that
we've done everything we can
I really don't know how people are gonna
react to this thing this could be
anything from a flop to a moderate
single there's something that it's
beyond what people's expectations are
you never know you never know good luck
keeping on we were in our own slipstream
a feeling like we were doing something a
little bit special and different but the
full circle of seeing that audiences
were reacting to it the way we had hoped
they would was powerful I had two dreams
when we started this little over 10
years ago Marvel Studios one was that I
meant working the other one was that we
could build something that was as
expansive and as experiential as what
people who read comics over the years
could get I had a lot of faith and Kevin
flag young people at Marvel you want to
give them everything you got cuz they're
gonna give everything that guy this was
a whole new journey by the first
Avengers but I thought oh well I think
we're onto something here just seeing
the characters together there's
something viscerally awesome about it I
think that's why the minute Sam Jackson
showed up at the end of Iron Man 1
whether people had read comics or not
who's that what does that mean why is he
here and then Tony Stark appearing at
the end of the Incredible Hulk
mr. intelligent we were putting a team
together who's we
though it seemed like just the tiniest
of things compared to where we are now
but those were the Foundation's that led
us here the cutting edge concept behind
the Marvel Universe is this massive
organism of shifting parts and new ideas
how do we do this as a team Seraphin is
responsible for all of these amazing
actors and extras that we brought into
this I think after the first Avengers
people realized that this was not just
an ordinary comic-book movie that there
was really a lot of thought and a lot of
care and a lot of passion that's going
into each and every one of these film
and there's also some joy I think when
the actors are having fun and creating
these characters that audiences feel bad
it's fulfilling that the characters have
just spoken to so many people all over
the world
[Music]
guru I love the fact that we've been
given the opportunity to do something
different put our set of ideas forward
and attack your character again and
hopefully advance on that and bring
something unique to it each time it's
wonderful to be able to play this iconic
character that means so much to people
and I really have to think the
audience's for that because they
embraced my portrayal of her from the
beginning final fitting what do you
think questions comments concerns and
allowed me to walk in Natasha's shoes
and kick ass in them too
I can tell you that each and every one
of us is so grateful
our lives are monumentally changed by
our involvement in this world to have
taken such an instrumental role in what
Marvel has done in the past ten years
it's just so incredibly meaningful to us
it's a cool experiment to be a part of
it's epic and classical these characters
are mythological characters in a lot of
ways I love all of you and I look
forward to seeing many of you as we
trudge this road of happy destiny it's
nice to look at how the legacy is living
on and these other movies and other
filmmakers I don't think this has ever
happened before in cinematic history of
all these different franchises colliding
and all these storylines they've started
such a long time ago have all woven
together you guys as the film's have
progressed with civil war and now
infinity war we're just gonna continue
to surprise people
there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people to see if we
could become something more
[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie that was a
really long featurette but as we're
getting closer to infinity war obviously
they're looking back on marble its 10th
anniversary its Marvel Studios 10th
anniversary not Marvel Comics obviously
but I think everybody understand what's
going on it's just that you have this
big movie coming out on a big
anniversary so you have two different
kinds of celebrations that they're all
sort of tying up together so in addition
to all those just straight-up infinity
war stuff that's happening inside the
movie they'll also be doing a lot of
really cool behind-the-scenes stuff like
the second part of this clip so if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the Marvel
videos there's gonna be crazy infinity
war happening next week there's a new
round of that Infinity Gauntlet giveaway
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber leave a comment on the video
and after we talk about this new footage
I'll explain what's going on with my
non-spoilery review and when all Easter
eggs and those kinds of videos will be
posting next week because it's all
coming next week so now is the time to
start freaking out but the really cool
part about this like just a couple funny
additional lines of dialogue we cool
yeah we're cool so cool some additional
moments from that funny scene where the
guardians meet team Iron Man who are you
were the Avengers man Tony looks at him
like ah Jesus is it gonna be like this
the whole time like probably right after
he dubs him an Avenger so he's just like
oh give it a minute kid just chill a
little bit
then obviously you have a little bit of
that Titan battle that we haven't seen
before just more creative use of portal
so like I posted that video where
star-lord is going boom and he backs out
through one of dr. Strange's portals but
now we have spider-man swinging through
one of these portals now most of what we
seen of him is just swinging around with
his webbing like he normally would with
all this crazy flying debris around but
what looks like happens here he's
already swinging mid-flight when Doctor
Strange does his version of a fastball
special so someone's already moving very
fast you open up a portal it would work
with someone like Quicksilver - the
funny WTF balance of this moment - is
that it's really awesome action like
holy crap that's badass but then he sort
of just bounces off of fan oats because
Stannis is so tough but the bruisers
have already said that he's supposed to
be stronger than the Hulk
with invincible skin now I you know I
don't know if that's invincible if
you're also wielding an infinity gem
that's probably the way to get him like
vision would probably be able to crack
some of his skin with the mind gem but
as a way of kind of showing you how
tough he is Iron Man has that double
bladed energy blade and it looks like
it's just gonna bounce right off of him
like that would shear through almost
anything because Tony's arc reactors are
so powerful what better way to show you
how hopeless it is for them then a bunch
of them teaming up with their upgrades
not being able to dent Thanos at all
even when he doesn't have all the
infinity gems they want to show you that
even without the completed gauntlet
that's how much of a badass Thanos is so
when he gets all six it's supposed to be
unthinkable
unstoppable so you go oh my god and then
they probably just dip to black but we
don't really know what the cliffhanger
is I will do post credit scene videos
and theories before the movie posts and
then obviously next week what's going to
happen is is my non-spoilery review is
allowed to post on Tuesday so of course
that's when that video will come I'm
allowed to do social media reactions on
Monday so for the most part the videos
that I do for the movie will follow the
same schedule that I do for all big
Marvel movies like the movie doesn't
drop in theaters everywhere till like
Thursday so spoilery stuff like post
credit scene videos Easter eggs that
won't post til the end of next week but
for the most part next week in the week
after that will be like a ton of
Avengers related stuff and once we get
through infinity war I'll start doing
Avengers 4 videos Captain Marvel ant-man
and the wasp so just leave all your
bonus video requests in the comments
below and I'll name a new giveaway
winner when I post new Marvel so click
here for more brand new Avengers and
click here for my flash video from
tonight thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome we'll see you
guys tonight
[Music]